I'm trying to increase my MMS dosage to get up to the cancer throtocall, a key perxied
that have to back off. Progress is slow, is the perxied are actually a good sign that the MMS is finding stuff to kill.
Well, I'm probably asking the wrong person because I'm not a big fan of the MMS protocol for cancer.
The reason is that MMS is going to be more physiologically a killer of living organisms, like bacteria or a fungus or something like that, that it is going to be a cancer.
It's not going to be attractive to cancer cells, of course, say.
And you've got to define whether you're really having a perx reaction or you're having a toxicity reaction from the MMS because MMS is a toxin.
I don't know. I mean, if you really feel like you should be doing the MMS protocol, then by all means continue to do it.
Lots of times when people have product lines, they're doing the MMS.
And those same people with product line will be making a comment like this if they're getting a perx reaction.
In other ways, whenever you feel lousy after taking something, it's not always a perx reaction.
Sometimes it's toxicity reaction from the thing you're taking.
Sometimes it's stimulated on a muter reaction.
MMS wouldn't do that, but a lot of people with line can play it up, they're doing it on like a cat's plot, they'll call it something like that and then they're perxied.
They're fighting through it. They'll probably not hurt see you're probably stimulated on a muter reaction.
You're having cell death at which we have antibodies against.
So it's not really a hurt scratch at all. I just don't know in your case, if it is or not.
I would make sure you're getting blood work done and make sure we're looking at.
At your.
On liver markers.
If those are all clean and your alkaline positive normal STLT is normal, maybe it's a herx reaction.
I don't know that I have tested anybody in the last 10 years with cancer that tested positive for illness.
So I'm not a good person to ask about that.